YouTuberって
誰と恋したらいいと思う？
この空気を見る限り察してくれ
今日は大人な話だ
まぁ、じっくり話そうぜ
まぁ、皆さんはさまざまな悩みがあると思います
その悩みを話せる場所の一つとして
SNSがあると思います
Twitterとか、Facebookとか、Google+、インスタ、LINE
まぁ、皆さんご存知のとおり僕はですね、
ぶっちゃけTwitterしかほぼ使ってません
気軽につぶやけるんですよね
僕の本名を言わなくても、僕はTwitter楽しめてますし、
気軽な絡みでできるんで、僕はTwitterをよく使っています
あ、まぁ、ちょっと最近ちょっと困りごとがありまして、
気になる？気になる？
気になっちゃう感じ？
俺の困りごと、
あ、うざい？
本気で悩んだ時ってねTwitterとかで言わないんですよ
僕のことを一方的に知っている人たちのほうが多いわけじゃないですか
まぁ、どっちかというとね、リプライちょうだいとか、返事ちょうだいとか、コメント返せとか、
無視すんな、ふざけんな、バカにしてんのか、何で返さねんだ、
最低！
みたいなことをたまに言われてしまうんですよTwitterだとね
やっぱこうリアリティがないんすよ
Twitterはどっちかというとリアリティに欠けたSNSだと僕は思っています
本名さらさなくていい、相手の顔もわからない、相手が誰だかわからない
そんな状況で生み出される会話
その中に果たして我々の本当の心の言葉はあるのか…
まぁ、無いとは言わないよ
無いとは言わないし、僕も思ったことをちゃんと言うときもあります
まじめに答えてくれるって言われるとそういうわけではない
悪ふざけもあるし、いたずらのようなコメントもある、誹謗中傷もある
まぁ、それだけだと
僕の相談にはのれないよ
っていう結論になっちゃうんすよ
Twitterだとちょっとユルすぎるなっというのと、
Facebookだと本名じゃいけないとかあって
僕の知っているリアルな友達にしか相談ができないっていう弱点がある
なんでTwitterもFacebookもちょっと違うなと思いまして
なにかいいSNSはないかと思ったんですけども
まぁ、もっと気軽に聞けるけどちょうどいい匿名性で相談できるようなSNS
ありました
そう、皆さんご存知mixiのコミュニティでございます
まぁ、mixi皆さん知ってると思うんですけども
もはや日本最大級のユーザー数を誇るSNSであって
共通の趣味を持った人同士がmixiコミュニティで通じてつながったり
音楽とか、スポーツとか、芸能とか、
すっごい多彩なコミュニティという場所が270万個以上あるのが特徴です
TwitterとFacebookの中間っていうわけじゃないんですけど
mixiなら匿名性で結構まじめに答えてくださる方も多いみたいなんで
一つ僕が相談したいトピックスを作りました
では実際にその内容を見ていきましょう
はい、というわけで僕の悩みというか、ガチな質問的な感じかな
ちょっとマジで聞きたいことがあるんで見てみましょう、こちら
えっと、内容がこういうものでございます
あんまり恋愛の話しねえから
恥ずかしいな
「はじめしゃちょーが最近恋について悩んでいるらしい。
彼女ができねぇ、、、これからもずっとできないのかな、、、
YouTuberの恋について、みんなの意見を聞きたいでござる！
みんなではじめしゃちょーの悩みに答えてみよう！」
っていう内容になってるんですけども
まぁちょっと、まぁちょっと聞いてくれや
ちょっと聞いてくれや
YouTuberの恋について
YouTuberというものはどんなものかと僕考えたんですよ
非常に難しいです
あの結構ガチな話をすると正直もう今、日中外を歩けないんですよ
街を歩いているともういろんな方にありがたいことに声をかけていただいてとてもありがたい
いや、そういうありがたい話じゃない
いや、感謝しております、ありがとうございます
あれ、なんか話がおかしくなってきたw
で、なるべく時間があれば写真撮りたいと思ったら写真撮るんですけども
それをしていると僕の一日が終わってしまったり、
予定がかなり狂ったりすることが結構あって
正直もう日中はほぼ外に出れないんですよ、僕
もし僕が外に彼女を連れて歩いていたとしたら
その彼女をみんな見るわけじゃないですか
なんかね、やっぱ盗撮とかもされるんですよ
盗撮とかもされてね、もしその盗撮されたときに
俺のその彼女がもし映り込んでたらその彼女も盗撮されてて
俺は別にねまぁ盗撮されても　いー
やだよ
俺もやだよ、俺もやだけど、彼女がよいとしましょう、嫌だけどね
彼女がよいとしましょう
俺がよくてもその彼女はどうなるよ
もし、その彼女が一般の人だったらですよ
一般の人だったら、なんかこう
ネットで顔とかさらされて、周りになんかうじゃうじゃなんか言われたりするかもしれない
非常に悲しい
俺はそんなので恋人を傷つけたくないんすよ
だからね、こう一般の人と付き合っても普通にデートできないのかなと思ってさ
ってなるとだよ
一般の人とデートできなくなるというというと、次狙うとしたら誰だ？
YouTuberか？芸能人？はい？女優さん？
難しい！
誰と付き合えば僕は誰にもなにも言われず平穏に暮らせるのかなと思ってですね
今回の悩みは僕のだけの悩みじゃありません
YouTuberの恋ってどうすればいいのっていう感じです
彼女ができないというかね
どう付き合えばいいのかなってもしできたときにね
今回たくさんの方からコメントいただきました
じゃちょっと読んでいきましょう
「嘆いていると出来るものもできない。まずは好きな人を見付ける」
まぁまぁそれはあると思うんですよ
好きな人を見つけることは大事だと思うんですけども
今なら言いましょう
僕が元カノと別れたなんか原因的なものは
まぁ、あんまりうまくは言えないんですけど
ちょっとYouTubeとかでこう外に出れなかったりね
忙しかったりして会う時間ができなかったっていうのが一つあります
好きだけじゃどうしようもできない壁があることを僕は知ってるんで
まぁ、好きな人見つけるっていうのは大事だと思うんですけど
まぁ、難しいとこですよね
ありがとうございます
「はじめしゃちょーっていう名前なんですね(^^)子供がたまにYouTubeで見てます(^3^)/」
「YouTubeで、恋人募集呼びかけたら、どうですか？
好みのタイプとか言うたら、素敵な出会いに巡り合えるかも(￣▽￣”)ゞ頑張って下さい。」
なるほど
それはありだな！
下の動画のURLから是非応募してくだs…
「アタック」かぁ
僕ですね女の人にアタックがほんとにできなくて
基本待たないとどうしようもできないというちょっとヘタレなんですけど
いや、俺攻めれねぇなぁ
ちょっとチキンだから攻めれないよ
あぁ、こういう感じでコメントがちゃんと残ります
「同郷ですが、県民適が保守的。」　これ間違いないっすよ、たぶん
僕、富山県民なんですけど、なんか富山県民はちょっと硬いというか
わかんない、雪国だからかしんないんですけど基本的にこう守りの姿勢です
みんながみんなそういうわけではないんですけど
「直感を信じる」「出会いを大切に」
「私は彼氏がYouTuberでも全然気にしないと思います！逆に手伝いたいです(笑)」
でも、難しいな、手伝わられたくないのかも知らない
動画撮るとき一人の世界に入っちゃうから、一緒にいると逆にできなくなる
たぶんそこが彼女のできない原因の一つだと思う
「ファンに手を出す」かぁ、
まぁまぁまぁありだと思いますけど難しいですよね
結局、ファンだったらさはじめしゃちょーのイメージでくるわけじゃん
で、もし、付き合ったら実際のはじめはすごい悪い人だったとか言われたら僕もたまったもんじゃないですよ
いや、そんなに現実と差はないと思うんですけど、まぁちょっと怖いですよね
「多分、YouTube撮影や編集が楽しすぎて忙しくて女性が近寄りがたくなっているのでしょう？」
あぁー、
ある
基本バタバタしています
そして、空いている時間には遊戯王かスプラトゥーンをしています
まさに、俺の生活に入る予知なし
「はじめにはトミックがいるじゃん。」
チェンジ
「ファンとの恋愛あり！ってゆってたから
はじめんがいいなら、オフ会とか交流会して出会いの輪を広げる！」
僕、動画じゃめっちゃバリバリしゃべってるんですけど、
超コミュ障で
基本人としゃべるのが
苦手です
オフ会とか開いても、もう、おいらペコペコしてるだけでそのまま終わっちゃいそうだね
はい、という感じでございました
まあ、僕はそんな焦ってないっすよ
どんな人がいいかな、どういう付き合い方していけばいいかなと思いました
まぁ、難しいっすよ
僕一人で動画撮りたいし
けど、一緒にいる時間をつくりたいけど、動画編集したいし
ゲームもしたいし、カードゲームもしたい
500件以上のコメント、本当にありがとうございました
とても参考になりました
まぁでも、僕もいつかは結婚したいと思ってるんでね
結婚したらね、こう、お嫁さんと一緒に動画を撮りたいっすね
一緒にクッキング動画を撮って
で、子供と一緒にね動画撮ってね
こう、みんなに成長の過程とかを見せたらなと思いますね
あぁ、妄想が膨らんでしまった
いや、すごい家族で動画撮るのはすっげぇ楽しいと思ってる
まぁ、将来的にそういうのが撮れたら楽しいのかなって思ったりしてます
はい、というわけでmixi、トピックを使ってたくさんの意見を知ることができました
みんな結構真面目に答えてくれててすごい参考になるのが多かったです
まぁ、Facebookだと本名だし友達にしか聞けないからなぁ
Twitterだとちょっとなんか軽い感じになっちゃうしなぁ
みたいに思っている人がいたらよかったらmixi使ってみてください
きっと真面目に答えてくれる人がいると思います
ではでは今後もですね、YouTuberがトピックを立てに来るらしいからよかったら是非チェックしてみてください
以上はじめしゃちょーのYouTuberの恋の悩みでした
じゃあな